وزاره الدفاع تايوانيه بتعقب خمسه طائرات
عسكريه و 30 حربيه صينيه في محيطي تايوان
صباح اليوم الخميس
اخترقت الجزء الجنوبيه الغربي من منطقه
الدفاع الجوي التونيه
المشتركه المتكرره حول الاراضي اليابانيه
اراضيها بحسن وتعبيره
وكانت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت ان
جيشها والجيش الصينيه اجر يا دواريات
دوريات مشتركه بمقاتلات الاستراتيجيه فوق
بحر اليابان وبحر الصين الشرقي
فقال مستشار الامن القومي
ان بلاده تعتمد نهج المنافسه لمواجهه
مواصفه بالتحدي الذي تفرضه الصين
في كوريا الجنوبيه اضاف سوليفان الولايات
المتحده تعمل بالتنسيق مع حلفائها
لتحقيقها
ايسكو
الاساسيه للتعامل مع التحدي الذي تطرحه
الصين واضح جدا
مع الحلفاء والشركاء بحيث نمضي قدما بشكل
مشترك في تحديد قواعد الطريق ومواجهه
جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه حيث نرى انها طرف
في افعال تؤثر على مصالحنا